んだあああああ
[音楽]
どうせお前らがやったんだろ半島
思うんですよね
そう
つまり犯人は
このの外遊
[音楽]
ん
ックいかにシべられるんだよ私の仕事があるんだよ待ってよ
何とって言うか違法としているなお枚れた仕事があるって言ってる何が万人だろんな
わけないから遅漏とするに決まってんだろうがええなんだも素人キレイ好きなのは誰だ
よと強いなぁ
いやー
そんなことしたって事件は解決しないだろうん
えっ
ところで君はこれ若山憲助
3段のマナーの同級生でたまたまこの辺通ったら一音聞こえたんだよ
みんな俺を樹脂化という誰だよ
ところでゼシカさんそっち十分ですね先生あなたので血が付いてませんか
[音楽]
犯人はお前だ
落ち着けね鶴岡くん
彼がまだ犯人という確証はないそうそうでふざけんだ
あなた
右手に何か隠してますねー
それは何ですか
[音楽]
拳銃がリアお前らああ
rar
den o 前田あああああ
par
ああああああ
いやー
わーなんでさぁどうした葉に被害者 c はしたんだったんだろ
じゃれじゃねえじゃねえかよ
確かに
だけどその犬種はなんじゃこりゃあああああ
rar
がんだろ
3段のバラの家にある監視官が見てくれよ
ボタンって
しています
バッハん
あああああ
ano ん
これは
何をしているんですか
時間敵では袖変化しているがなるほどなること
8番ですね逮捕しておきましょうついカッとなってうちはあったんだ
yeah
[音楽]
これまでの像を踏まえると
おそらくジェシカさん
あなたはこの事件の犯人じゃない
おそらく犯人は中を使った犯行をしていた
そして現場にあった某2を見るかけに視察であることは間違いないためジェシカな
ん
[音楽]
あなたは犯人じゃない鳥大があなたが彼を殺す大きなどういう見つけてしまった
先生その動機とは
するほどくん
彼の妻を見てくださいんあっ
はい
あなたと3段の薔薇さんはこの画像の通り
[音楽]
あなたたちが友達以上の関係にあったことはこの画像を通り確実なのです
先ほど様を盗み確認させていただきました何してんの安価
やめろだがつい最近破局
真ん中と3段の婆さんとのラインも凝っする見させていただきました
に入ってるんですか先生ラベてくれよもう
豆でももんがぁ
[音楽]
ベジェがあなたはから人ではありません
あなたの犯人ではない松岩さんとできていますから同期を得る必要がありましたか先生
[音楽]
スロー
すなぁ
ええええええ
あなたの容疑は晴れましたもう帰ってください気をつけて帰るんだぞ
さあ
心はあなたです
wh
薄 the ラーン臼澤さんは車の出張森林の仕事をなさっている方で事件当時は車の
下で3段の薔薇さんの車を修理していたそうです
なるほど
[音楽]
もう一度ず検討前の監視カメラは見てみましょう
確かにジェシカさんが変化している隣で車の種類をなさっています
そういう省刑事さん私は事件当時のアリバイがあるんですよあればいら
いいえ
それは何かわかりません
[音楽]
どこへ行くですか
犯行現場に行って確かめたいことがあるんです
ええええええ
ああああああ
[音楽]
ん
yeah
[音楽]
やっぱねー
どうしました方亭さん
このバッテリー
触ってみてください
[音楽]
tee
バッテリーがー
こんなにあったかい
さっきまで使われてみたいですそう
つまり
ドローンさんの可能性が高いということです
うささん
ず芸当
あなたは正しくないかなと
車はそんなやってい
ず厳冬を剤をしていたか
そうですよ
待ってください
確かに監視カメラその時私が何をしていたかは分からない私は道路運送さん
してません同五条下るんだドローン操作がこんなものは必要だろう
私はそんなものって車の下に入ってな確かに楽しかったれてみたところ
車の下に入るとき出るときにはドローンとコントローラーを持ってないです
オーラー私だなその代わりエロ持ってましたよ
チャージを白いいいじゃないよ音職労働者でいろいろ末になんない
てっぺんウェイでこれで私もありまー完全に証明された
銀英伝
まだわかりません
前もって車の下にドローンのコントローラを仕込んどいた可能性があります
鶴岡くん33いきましょうはい
[音楽]
だめです見当たりませんでしたなんだって
確かに監視カメその時私が何を閉めると
僕いいなって
none ありません
[拍手]
[音楽]
いいな条約全ての謎が
1本の線へ繋がりません
ん
鶴岡くん
調べてほしいことだった
[音楽]
voodoo
ようやく犯人がわかったんですねで
ようやくわかったんですよ
この絵で
一連の事件を巻き起こしたら犯人がね
先生その半島まずは犯行の手口を説明しましょう
公開の実現はいたでしブルー
[音楽]
包丁とドロー
この2つだけです
今回の事件は
犯人は直接被害者を殺していません
ドローンの創造に優れたといえば
セルボおりついたでしょう
この2つでターゲットを殺害できると思う
犯人は何らかの手段で時に入り込みいやそこが重要なんです
家の中でドローンのポーズを装備させターゲットが来たタイミングでドローンの飛行
開始
行動覗い産卵の薔薇さんだったら逃げること不可能だったでしょ
そんなに被害者を添えて使ってそして包丁を装備したドローン
通称 follow ん follow ンってなんすかせん follow ま
ちゃんパパだった
願って遅い方に彼をしません
いいはぁ
皆さん
もうはからでしょう
[音楽]
管理は
この中でいませんどういうことですか
結局
動けるを感じですね
じゃあ誰が犯人なんですよ犯人はおそらく別の遠距離からドローンそうさせています
多分自信ないんですか先生そしてあのいえば
3段1段二段に思っている
そこでを出させてあげたんです
彼の動画を先制その版にはそりゃ怒るでしょうね
なぜなら産卵の薔薇さんは会ったこともない犯人の挨拶を勝手にパクっていたですから
なんだっていく欄がないんがぁ
そんなことをこれほどの恨みを持ったところ
あいつしかいない
実はでふとうんちっ
韓流品エアー
わあああああ
ああああああ
me
teame
ni
car
バッハ